pour évoquer la situation en équateur
nous sommes en direct avec gabriella
bravo journaliste chilienne bonsoir
gabriela bravo merci d'être avec nous
l'équateur mais plus globalement
l'amérique latine nouvel épicentre de la
tant d'ennemis comment peut-on
l'expliquer selon vous en soirée or en
fait là l'épidémie suis lourd normal
d'une épidémie qui commence dans la
partie orientale globe et qui fasse
après vers l'occident s'est passé dans
la chine jusqu'en europe
et après c'est le cas de l'amérique
celle que normal d'une épidémie mais
c'est ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'elle
en amérique du sud en l'air d'autres
supérieur de m
d'automne on est dans l'otan est prêt à
passer à l'intérieur hivernale ce qui
peut à mon père a grandi à cette
épidémie puisse se développer encore
plus dans le continent pas simple en
europe qui on était en train de passer
vers le printemps
une chose importante c'est que à dire
c'est que cette épidémie a été ramené
par des voyageurs on va surtout des gens
aisés qui voyager en europe ou en asie
et c'est eux qui sont ramenés la maladie
l'épidémie dans le continent américain
car effectivement chacun ramène toujours
de toute façon la maladie dans un pays
c'était le cas également en europe
comment est perçue la gestion des
gouvernements des pays d'amérique latine
on parle beaucoup notamment du brésil
avec gestion un petit peu particulière
de jaillir un bol sauna au qui est
toujours au corona sceptiques et qui
suscite les inquiétudes de certains
observateurs dans cette gestion de la
crise
on peut voir qu'elle est juste qu ils
sont assez différents d'un pays à
l'autre mais en général
l'amérique latine n'a pas bien réagi à
cette épidémie
des paroles parce que les différences
économique entre et les écarts entre les
riches et les pauvres sont énormes
l'accès à la santé n'est pas égalitaire
et passons pour donner un chiffre
30% de la population de l'amérique
latine ne peut pas se soigner
correctement jusque là par des raisons
économiques et d'un pour cent de la
population ne pas accès à la santé par
des raisons géographiques
alors les présidents les les politiciens
en fait ils ont essayé de mettre des
mesures restrictives comme des
quarantaines donc de certains régions
dont d'en haut des quarantaines donc la
population mais par des récents et qu'on
a mis 45 n'ont pas été respectées
complètement ont n'ont pas été suivies
pour tous la population
on a souligné que dans plusieurs pays
notamment les états unis et même la
france ce sont les populations souvent
défavorisées qui était davantage touchés
par ce coronavirus on imagine que c'est
la même chose justement dans ces pays
d'amérique latine où vous venez de le
dire le fossé entre les pauvres et les
riches et est très accentué
exactement c'est parce que mon amérique
latine le travail informel atteint un
niveau très élevé
selon l' organisation internationale du
travail jusqu'à 50% de la population de
l'amérique latine fait un travail
informel la sécurité sociale n'est pas
comme ici comme en europe
ya pas d chômage dans tous les pays
seulement quelques pays dans des stades
aux gens qui sont dans le besoin
pour donner un exemple leur part
semblent le chili lé la rentrée en
quarantaine total dans la région dans la
capitale et a provoqué des émeutes de la
faim parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à se nourrir et nourrir
correctement les scores
vu qu'ils sont pas de travail pas se
nourrir justement il ya eu des
manifestations anti confinement
certainement pour ces raisons
économiques que vous évoquez ans au
brésil notamment est-ce que ça a été le
cas également dans d'autres pays
d'amérique latine des gens qui voulaient
justement condé confine pour pouvoir
aller travailler simplement
après les récents entre le fils et
d'autres pays sont différents parce que
on voit pas simple au brésil c'est des
manifestations comme on peut voir en
amérique du nord aux états unis pour
laisser l'économie suivre son cours
normal
pendant que par son père au chili en
colombie ensemble en colombie les gens
mais des chiffons rouges dans les
maisons ou montrer qu'ils sont ils
demandent par son club et la nourriture
ils demandent l argent des types de
l'état or pour que l'état ne les
abandonne pas je suis sérieux parce que
on vient de la 3 on a vécu une révolte
sociale d'une ampleur énorme dans ta
hier fait les coronavirus sait
maintenant un peu en ag les un peu le
conflit social dans l'amérique latine
mais il a fait aussi ses maîtres lui au
pouvoir les groupes différence qu'il ya
entre les riches et les pauvres donc
plus qu'à calmer la colère sociale
cette épidémie bien faire des
augmentations de tous ces conflits et il
fait la sortir de la pire façon possible
que c'est à travers l'énorme quantité de
morts surtout des populations les
priorités merci beaucoup gabriela bravo
nous avoir évoqué cette situation en
amérique latine